someone calls me with more bad news like
every five minutes it's just so
stressful
kendall Jenner opens up about her
involvement in the now infamous
political Pepsi commercial I would never
purposely hurt someone ever I just felt
so stupid the fact that I would offend
other people or hurt other people was
definitely not the intent
kendall was visibly upset on Sunday's
premiere of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians the backlash from the
politically charged commercial which
aired in April and was almost
immediately pulled made the 21 year old
model very emotional she expressed her
regret to big sister Kim Kardashian I
genuinely feel like I have no idea how
many bounce back from it this is the
first time you've had a scandal the only
thing you can really do is just be like
real and honest because you can't ignore
it when the commercial first aired
sources familiar with Kendall's Pepsi
contract told ET she was quote
devastated by the controversy at the
time Pepsi said in a statement quote we
also apologize for putting kendall
Jenner in this position